did you find a dog psychic yeah we did
where would you look for that uh it was
actually a recommendation from
one of the writers on the good place and
I was like all right yeah I guess we'll
try it okay so you went into it
skeptical yeah yeah and I I was wrong
um I mean basically he was like
flinching every time I reached to pet
him and uh and so we had this
appointment and she you know she she
called it we had been taking him to vets
and everything they couldn't figure out
what was wrong with him and she said
like he seems to be having some trouble
in his neck and so we uh we took him
back to the bed
and said like can you just x-ray his
neck and back for us and they're like
well we don't think anything's wrong but
yeah we'll go ahead and do that and then
they found that he has a herniated disc
and so I mean I had to check my little
skepticism at the door is it true that
you are also not necessarily a romantic
which is crazy because you met your lady
Ali during a production of Romeo and
Juliet yeah well which is like the most
romantic story ever told yeah so like
when it happened was
um we we had known each other for a
while and we were friends first we were
friends first and we met when we were
with other people and you know we
understood yeah
see it works doesn't it so I I was
already cast as Romeo in this thing and
they were looking for Juliet and I asked
if she had a gig for the summer and she
was like no I don't I'm like well do you
want to audition for this thing that I'm
doing and she was like yeah sure and she
went in she killed it she got it and
then we uh it you know that was that and
then you
so now are you a little bit more of a
softie
you know I'm I'm soft with with her and
you know like we're definitely I reserve
softness for her but otherwise I'm you
know I I can be a bit of a cynic
sometimes and she's sort of like kind of
shakes that out of me
um so I'm I'm glad that you do have that
romance in your life because you deserve
that I'm so happy for you
um okay we have a clip of your um role
in Ant-Man and the WASP uh Quantum Mania
let's take a look and then we'll get
into it how do you how did you know that
he's quas he's a telepath
you can read minds yeah and I really
wish I couldn't everyone
is disgusting hmm
could you please stop thinking that
sorry please stop thinking thinking that
I'm trying
well not very hard and I think you look
weird too
[Applause]
so you play quas this is you know MCU
this is his biggest fandom gets how are
you feeling about the movie how do you
like the fans
what's it like
being a part of this world it's I mean
it's kind of a dream come true for me I
mean I'm I'm such a geek for these
movies so you are on mcuer are you a fan
yes I am I am because it's exciting I
mean the like when I was growing up I
would see people like sleeping on the
street in in backpacks and and sleeping
blankets yeah and it's like they would
be lining up for
I love you I would they would be lining
up for like Star Wars you know and it
was my first glimpse into the way people
felt about films that's why I feel so
excited for the MCU world because I feel
like it's how I grew up and The
Impressions that left on me were so
positive oh man
[Applause]
so and you are claws yeah
um now quas is also very close to quasar
yeah I I've seen those conspiracy
theories I um I you know I don't know I
don't know what they have planned for
this character and so if they have more
plans for quas I'm down obviously but
you know like it's it's it's what it is
like I'm happy to just have this you
know what an exciting time yeah
well thank you
William Harper Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania is in theaters now but you
all know that
[Music]
foreign